when I'm really I've been really looking
forward to talking to you because I saw
and I think that the timing of it was
when ignite went public all of a sudden
like the in-going public the financial
records of the company are are made
public for all to see and there was just
what looked like a wave of like
Financial YouTubers just saying oh this
is a slam dunk like oh ignite's gonna
declare bankruptcy any minute now it's a
and like I'm like I'm waiting I'm
waiting and yeah they've been waiting
for like three years for that so so
basically so it went public I think in
like 18 it kind of like went public like
right off the bat
um but then the financials are a little
bit delayed
um
and I think it was basically like when
covid really hit and I was and I was
moving out of the house in LA because we
couldn't throw parties
um you know our like production got
stopped in China it was like this whole
thing so we're like okay let's cut costs
and we're really like selling the wrong
product honestly that was the real
issues like we came into the thing doing
weed but you're only in a certain you
know couple of states and 80 of my
following is outside the US right so I'm
like dropping atomic bombs on ant hills
every time I do a post it's like all
these people they want to buy the
product but there's no product to sell
them right so when we switch over to the
nicotine the Vapes then it was like you
know bam like worldwide everybody can
get them we can ship them better margins
just entirely Better Business there's
not a lot of guys in the pot business
killing it at all I think like burner
might be the only one
um just because you're competing with
the black market they don't have to test
their [__] you know there's like
they're not paying taxes you tax the
legal guys like the same as cocaine
dealers it's 280 so like they get no
write-offs it's just a brutal business
they can't Banks they're dealing with
cash basically all the negatives of like
doing an illegal business but like it's
technically legal and when you're
competing against other guys that aren't
playing by the rules so it's like
they're not testing their products they
don't have to wait so it's like and
they're going direct to Consumer they're
not paying 18 million dollars for
[__] license so Martin's not to be as
high it's like this whole thing right so
we got out of that that was a [__]
godsend but the real like Halo press
came down we fired our CEO so our CEO we
fired him he was like I honestly think
they do was like doing drugs he's so
erratic like I think he had like a real
problem but anyways like multiple CEOs
like you kind of cycled through a number
of them yeah I think he was like our
third one right so we got rid of him and
he did this whole like whistleblower
thing and like went to the Press he
basically like was trying to like
blackmail us for money and we're like
[__] you we're not paying you he goes to
the Press like you know they're blowing
money they're doing this they're doing
that and so the Press did some articles
and then all the YouTube guys jumped on
that bandwagon right and we like weren't
profitable we lost like I think it was
like 50 million dollars which if you
think about like the grand scheme of a
company like uber lost like five billion
and a quarter you know what I mean
there's like a lot of like really
valuable companies that aren't even
profitable like Tesla is like not
profitable for a long time yeah and
Netflix isn't profitable I think there's
a ton of them you know there's a ton of
so like when you're starting a business
and you're and you're building a brand
like many times you're not going to be
profitable especially you know we're in
the wrong business so
there was like that whole thing and then
like every YouTuber jumped on and it was
just like negative press negative press
and I thought about addressing it but it
was like a weird thing because you know
these YouTube guys you got a million
views two million views but every post
of mine is getting 40 50 million [__]
views so it's like do I want to like
shine a big [__] light on these
[__] right and I think it would have
been like it would have been different
if like CNN did some [__] you know right
but it was like these random YouTube
kids so I just chose to like focus on my
book and like not really like address it
but then that kind of like sent a
wildfire of like you know all this like
uncontested stuff and you know as you
know like the bad press always does
better than the good press so yeah I was
like it was crazy you know I'm like
worth 350 million dollars these people
like he's going broke he's fleeing the
country I'm just like what the [__] like
green completely I agree completely with
that approach
um you know I think uh silence is the
deadliest weapon for sure but I think
that when that was stuff was going on
you did get pretty quiet on your
Instagram and did you not post for a
while there yeah so I was writing that
book for two years man okay dude I
legitimately wrote the whole [__]
thing and did like all but one at it
myself so it was a [__] big project I
just put out my second book I wrote it
with the co-writer and man it's the
gnarliest amount of work
yeah well I was in a reader and I wasn't
a [__] writer so like
500 well it started 708 pages so like
you know a book that like reduced to 500
pages is a [__] like big undertaking
for a guy that doesn't write and then
doing all your edits like minus one I
did 36 to 37 so yeah do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude